great super birdie out here this morning
my name is r.j. pastry dough I am the
Graduate Dean at the college and a
professor of politics and I am chairing
this panel on the future of the
Democratic Party we have three very
distinguished panelists I will each was
going to speak for no more than 15
minutes and I'll introduce each speaker
as he's about to come up to the podium
and then following the initial
presentations we'll have some discussion
among the panelists and throw things
open to questions from the audience
we're going to begin with Douglas Schon
Douglas shawn has been one of the most
well known Democratic campaign
consultants for over 40 years he was a
founding partner and former principal
strategist for the polling and
consulting firm Penn shown in Berland
and he's also the founder and principal
of Douglas shone LLC in New York City
his political clients his political
clients have included former President
Bill Clinton as well as former New York
City Mayor Michael Bloomberg as you
probably know he's a regular contributor
to The Wall Street Journal to the
Washington Post various other newspaper
and online publications as well as Fox
News please join me in welcoming Douglas
Schon
well first of all thank you for the kind
introduction I'm very pleased to be here
and I think in answer to one of the
questions that I frequently get yes I am
still a Democrat barely and I say that
and you know one of the problems I have
doing this panel with two extraordinary
minds particularly someone in bill
Galston I say that Anzu particularly
because he frequently writes in the
journal what I'm thinking before I've
even had a chance to crystallize my
thoughts and so bill if I plagiarize you
or an otherwise take a bit of your
thunder I would would apologize but I
era where the two parties were
relatively close that there were
moderate Republicans and conservative
Democrats I count myself now as a
moderate to conservative Democrat more
in the I'd say scoop Jackson Hubert
Humphrey mold the very few of us left I
wrote down in my notes a dinosaur and
while I hope that's an exaggeration
since I see none of you laughing I
realized it's not too much of an
exaggeration we live in a world now that
I find as a Democrat and I daresay as an
American deeply distressing and deeply
disorienting because no matter what your
view is of policy outcomes we are all
Americans we have American interests and
we have an in my judgment an overarching
need to pursue them as Americans not as
conservatives not as moderates not as
liberals but as Americans you hear that
occasionally less so than used to but
the number of people who really believe
that is precious view and as a
democratic centrist who was hawkish on
foreign policy I find myself a very very
lonely man I also find myself lonely in
another area again bill I apologize
have bills written a column on what I'm
about to say and so I don't mean to be
too impertinent but and I'll put it in
the form of a question how many of you
have heard Democrats this year on the
campaign trail of any ideological strike
talking about job creation growing the
economy preparing people for
technological jobs or jobs that may
exist I haven't heard it and it startles
me because when you look at the polling
data if the economy is not number one
it's certainly
number two or three and if we get any
sort of downturn into the 2020 election
it is absolutely the case that the
economy will be front and center
the top issue to my way of thinking in
the absence of any discussion of growth
and job creation we focus to a degree
that I find almost unimaginable on
redistribution of wealth the
comprehensive set of policies from
increasing taxes on the wealthy wealth
taxes increasing inheritance taxes to me
offers a very clear and compelling
narrative of what the Democratic Party
has come to stand for and every new
policy that gets articulated if there is
a huge price tag associated with it such
as the green New Deal you hear well the
wealthy should pay more i I dare say
that that is neither an economic
strategy nor is it a strategy on climate
change nor is it something that in my
mind is reasonable and responsible at
all the other thing that's not
reasonable and responsible to me is
where we stand with the federal debt and
deficit and as one of those in the mid
90s who pushed Bill Clinton very hard to
do a balanced budget to reduce the debt
and deficit to compromise with Newt
Gingrich and I believe if I'm right bill
left the country with a small surplus
when the Clinton administration was over
I am appalled that we have a deficit now
that is in the trillions of dollars and
there is nobody I mean and if there is
somebody and I missed it I apologize but
I don't hear anyone of any real
significance talking about that or the
implications of that for social programs
indeed we tried in the 90s to have a
dialogue about Social Security
entitlement programs Medicare Medicaid
Social Security and a way to preserve
and protect them for the future Paul
Ryan fried and what I thought was a
somewhat ham-handed way obviously it
didn't work so well he's now seeking
other employment but that being said I
would think a responsible political
party would want to talk about
entitlements the budget and our future
and again my party says nothing about
that rather the emphasis is on
redistribution and something else that I
find equally disarming just and
disturbing which is the sectarian
conflict between the left and what's
left of the moderate wing of the party
and the fact that we are engaging both
on the presidential level and indeed in
terms of primaries with the so-called
Justice Democrats in this
Squad in this fratricidal process will
only serve to make more challenging for
the Democrats the difficulty and
ultimately prevailing at the
presidential or congressional level
level in 2020 the question you would
obviously ask and of course given that
I'm here I would have to answer is well
what's going to happen in the nominating
process mister shown you've presumably
have been close to it I did work for
Mayor Bloomberg last I guess last year
and early this year when he made a
determination that he would not seek the
presidency and I certainly understand
why he said that he did not see with Joe
Biden running room for two moderates
because the nature of the party has
changed to the point where they both the
energy and the enthusiasm as we saw in
the new Wall Street journal/nbc poll is
with the left and the size of the the
number of voters who will vote for a
left-wing candidate appears from what I
can see looking at that poll today and
looking at the poll that bill put in his
column in The Journal today to be
somewhere 4050 percent of the primary
electorate so okay given all that where
do we stand that poll they the NBC Wall
Street Journal poll has a gap of five
points between Biden and Warren that to
me
spells dire dire problems for Joe Biden
whose challenges on the campaign trail
are well known see
and certainly something either others
will discuss we could discuss among
ourselves or with the audience but
certainly Biden doesn't have what you'd
call growth potential Warren clearly
does I don't know how many of you have
followed what she said but it is as
anti-capitalist as you would ever want
to imagine now she says she's a
capitalist but says when insurance
companies charge high premiums and have
the temerity to try to minimize their
payouts that there's something
fundamentally wrong with that process I
can understand why she might want to
alter their health system but the idea
of using a presidential election to
effectively eviscerate our traditional
notions of capitalism and free markets
does not sound like again the democratic
party that I joined as a very young man
when I was moved to involvement by John
F Kennedy and I cite for those of you
old enough to remember I think it was a
tax cut it was I think it was 63 and
Kennedy saying rising tides lift all
lifts all boats or something like that
certainly this is a very very different
party now but I think given the
tightness of the polling that bill cited
this morning in New Hampshire I think
what we've seen in Iowa with Warren
within a couple of points a button I
think Warren given her the enthusiasm
she's generating 20,000 people in
Washington Square Park I guess two days
ago I think she's become the favorite
for the nomination and if you've noticed
what Donald Trump has done he's been
attacking Biden with his campaign videos
for his gaffes
he's largely left senator Warren alone
and I think his hope is to run against
her to run against the far left
Democratic Party and to make Warren
the squad and the left effectively
interchangeable do I think it's likely
to be effective well let's put it this
way Trump is in a position where he is
eminently beatable his numbers are
terrible the way he conducts himself
whether you agree with him or not
is really not what the American people
want their president to do he flip-flops
his approval rating is now in the low
40s some polls have had it in the high
30s he should be somebody who is easy to
beat but I don't believe that's going to
be the case I think Warren will be a
tough tough general election candidate
for the electorate to deal with
particularly swing voters in the Midwest
and if I had to bet I had bet on in a
close election with Donald Trump having
an advantage despite all the liabilities
and political problems that he now has
look if we face a recession of the type
we saw in 2008 all bets are off and we
might be looking at a Warren Sanders
administration but barring that was also
a joke I don't think she'd run with
Sanders but again the absence of any
reaction tells you what you think and I
think of where the Democratic Party is
so I'll stop on that note and leave it
to my colleagues to perhaps offer a more
informed and thoughtful presentation
that I have thank you
thank you very much
next speaker will be William Eggleston
whom many of you will recognize from his
weekly column that he writes for The
Wall Street Journal he also holds the
Ezra Zilka chair in the Brookings
Institution's Governance Studies Program
and that's where he serves as a senior
fellow and prior to January of 2006 he
was the saul stern professor and acting
dean at the School of Public Policy at
the University of Maryland and I should
add that dr. Galston was also the deputy
assistant to President Clinton for
domestic policy from 1993 to 1995 please
join me in welcoming him well it's a
pleasure to be here thank you for coming
out early in the morning to listen to
these reflections on the future of the
Democratic Party just a few comments and
what we've just heard as a partially
defrocked academic I have always viewed
plagiarism as the sincerest form of
flattery and I am duly flattered you
know as for you know you know as for
budget as for budget deficits president
clinton delivered four years of
surpluses in a row four consecutive
surpluses to the extent that the former
Fed chair alan greenspan was wringing
his hands about the possibility that the
debt would be paid down and eliminated
making it very much more difficult for
the global financial system to make use
of you as dead as a safe harbor that was
twenty two trillion dollars ago i should
also say that i was at a small event
with Senator Michael Bennet last night
who is also running for president and
you would have heard everything you
wanted to hear
about economic growth and educational
opportunity I understand
yep he also understands that Senator
Gary Hart was at 1% at a comparable
point in 1983 so it's you know but this
is this being a Hillsdale audience I
will recur to first principles you know
as you all know the US Constitution
makes no explicit provision for
political parties you also know that the
founders did not anticipate the
development of a party system and they
certainly did not want one but within
just a few years after the inauguration
of the Constitution on the beginning of
our constitutional order we had in
effect a two-party system and with some
bumps in the road and occasional detours
we've had a two-party system ever since
the two-party system appears to be our
constitutional fate is this bad news I
think not because it turns out that in
an increasingly large and diverse
country political parties turn out to be
essential ways of organizing arguments
about the future of the country and that
is the ultimate justification of our
party system or more precisely to
propose responses to the major problems
facing our country within the framework
of defensible interpretations of our
constitutional order now this role for
the parties involves in part debatable
specifications of what these problems
are sometimes the parties agree on what
the problems are
only disagree about responses or
solutions today is sometimes happens
there's disagreement between the parties
both about the most important problems
facing the country and the nature of the
solutions to be offered nonetheless let
me you know I have come neither to bury
the Democratic Party nor to praise it
but to analyze the current situation
facing the party and the country so let
me let me offer a list of what I think
most people or would agree are problems
confronting the country first you know
the economic and social consequences of
the profound economic transformation
that we have been ongoing undergoing for
decades
and continue to undergo with a constant
wave of technological technological
innovation second the implications of
increasing demographic diversity which
is baked into our population even if we
slam the doors entirely shut on
immigration tomorrow what are the
implications of this demographic
diversity for Public Policy and also for
social cohesion the clash which i think
is quite a systemic clash between what
I'll call traditional and progressive
cultural outlooks shifting gears the
economic and military implications of
China's rise for America's role in the
world
authoritarian challenges to the post-war
hegemony of liberal democracy and
finally and I would add on a
constitutional note the implications of
the hollowing out of Congress and the
shift of power both to the executive
branch and to the judiciary now because
our large and diverse country has only
two major parties thanks to our
first-past-the-post system each party of
necessity is a coalition with internal
differences and also fissures within
today's Democratic Party there are
disagreements about the best responses
to the challenges that I've enumerated
and because of that it is the parties
caucuses and primaries will that will
determine the agenda that the Democratic
Party presents to the country as an
alternative to a Republican party which
is now dominated as rarely before by the
figure and the orientation of the
Republican present president so simply
put the present of the Democratic Party
is an argument about the future of the
Democratic Party and what's going on in
the primary in this primary season maybe
disorderly but it is not trivial because
it is an argument about the future of
one of the two great in enduring
political parties in this country now
what is the argument about within the
Republican Party rather than the
Democratic Party well in part it's an
argument about economics how much and
what kind of government intervention is
needed to rectify the imbalances that
have developed in different sectors of
the economy and I would argue among
different regions of the country and
this these regional divisions are real
and consequential and worrying so what
is the right balance of market-based
mechanisms and command and control
measures to what extent is the
increasing concentration of ownership
among fewer and fewer businesses in many
sectors of the economy
a problem for growth in innovation a
problem that the Antitrust Division of
the Justice Department in the Trump
administration is now wrestling with can
a partnership with corporate America be
consistent with the objective of
economic growth that benefits all
classes and regions or should the
Democratic Party treat corporate America
as a foe that must be brought to heel
there are many other there are many
other divisions within the party on
immigration on health care is it
Obamacare Obamacare plus a public option
Medicare for all
what should we do with our troops in
Afghanistan the so-called endless war
should they be pulled out
unconditionally
should we demand tougher conditions than
Zomba thenns al Khali LOD has so far
should we leave them there indefinitely
what about the trans-pacific partnership
I think it's fair to say that senator
Elizabeth Warren would like to get to
know on the TPP and former Vice
President Biden would like to get to yes
what about the size of the defense
budget some Democratic candidates
believe that the defense budget is about
right sized and others think it's much
too big how much of an enemy is China
are we facing a new cold war or does
China present us with a mix of
competition and cooperation there's also
political disagreement does President
Trump represent an historical detour as
Joe Biden would have it or an historical
discontinuity as many other Democrats
believe and in parallel with that is the
task of the Democratic Party to get the
country back to normal
which is more or less the Biden position
whatever you
think normal is or is it radical
structural change which is the deep
which is the basic position of the left
wing of the Democratic Party what's
going to happen I don't know I genuinely
don't know if things continue as they're
know going we are looking in effect
structurally speaking at a rerun of the
2016 primary between Hillary Clinton and
Bernie Sanders although the figures
representing those two different forces
in the party are are different you know
I agree that at this point the force
appears to be with Senator Warren on the
other hand her her appeal is to a
relatively small slice of the overall
demography of the Democratic Party and
the african-american vote is key after
the early primaries and caucuses and
there Joe Biden has fully fifty percent
support he doesn't seem to be losing it
so I think it's fair fight there's no
way of predicting the outcome for sure
but I can say this history is a series
of sequential consequential
contingencies each one shaping the range
of possibilities for the next it is
inevitable that the debate in today's
Democratic Party will be shaped in part
by the powerful figure of Donald Trump
and what he represents and the
Democratic Party is wrestling with the
question of the best argument to make
what President Trump against what
President Trump represents given the
fact that some of what he represents
overlaps with at least some of what the
Democratic Party believes thank you very
much
[Applause]
well thank you our third speaker this
morning will be Andrew Sullivan who is a
contributing editor at New York Magazine
and is also a blogger and an author he
was the New Republic's youngest
editor-in-chief and he also worked for
time for the New York Times Magazine and
served as a senior editor for the
Atlantic he joined New York magazine as
a contributing editor in 2016 where he
covers politics and culture and
occasionally writes features he also has
two new books one is titled keeping the
faith which is a spiritual memoir about
the future and meaning of Christianity
in the 21st century and he has a 30 year
retrospective of essays and reviews
titled thinking out loud please join me
in welcoming Andrew Sullivan
[Applause]
thank you very much I'm just to clear up
a small small point of fact the last two
books that like that you cited have not
yet been written they've been put on
hold until the Trump period is concluded
in some way or other just for the record
I'm not a Democrat never have been but
neither have I ever been a Republican
the only thing I've ever been really is
a Tory and I was very sort of on on the
rocks let's put it that way so just a
few thoughts about what has been said
and what what we're talking about for I
think this is an incredibly fertile
moment for the left I think for a couple
of obvious reasons and you see this not
just here but in Europe as well and the
first is that clearly market capitalism
is failing most people in the West the
ability to actually raise most people's
sound of living to afford a house to
afford college all the core things that
people want to make themselves a better
life I have someone whispering in my ear
here okay where was I moaning capitalism
is failing clearly failing and this is
creating a huge demand especially among
the younger generations for radical
reform if you look at the next two
generations views on the core issues of
all the issues of right and left they
are further left than in any time since
the 30s they don't like capitalism for
the first time really a generation of
Americans do not like it and you can see
and same also in in the United Kingdom
which I know a little bit about you can
see that's also the case in in the UK
how to fix this how to fix the fact that
everybody's working harder than ever
and only a tiny proportion people are
benefiting massively that's the question
that people are asking and secondly I
think the other issue that is propelling
the left is the climate crisis that as
the world hurtles towards unprecedented
climate turbulence and mass migration as
a consequence obviously government has a
role to play in preventing such a
catastrophe from unfolding and most
people especially those again on the
forty that will have to live in that
world want change big change in order to
prevent that happening so it is in my
view a really fertile time a program for
redistribution of wealth has enormous
potential as a vote winner whether you
agree with it or not radical efforts to
prevent climate change are increasingly
popular and it should be I think a
walkover why it isn't a walkover why in
fact the Democrats and the left in
general are struggling is is very
interesting see in the last general
election in the United Kingdom the
Labour Party led by Jeremy Corbyn the
most far left individual in the history
of British politics that alone as Prime
Minister once he laid out his manifesto
at the beginning of the campaign which
is basically massive redistribution
building of houses and and an over over
overhauling of market capitalism the
United Kingdom he gained 20 points the
campaign that is why the Tories are in
such problem because the Labour Party's
message of redistribution he's actually
increasingly popular I think there are
two reasons this is not working for the
left and the first is immigration that
people are prepared I think to move to
the
quite radically on economics but unless
they're reassured in this very turbulent
time that their countries aren't simply
open borders to anybody who wants to
come there they're not going to get a
hearing the Democrats position on
immigration is now so far to the left so
far towards open borders that it
disqualifies them in the minds of many
other people who still believe that
there is such a thing as the
nation-state there are such things as
borders and the Democratic Party seems
to be completely oblivious of this the
second reason is intersectionality it is
the shift within the left away from the
economic Marxism to a cultural Marxism
in which the various groups I don't need
to explain this at Hillsdale individuals
are characterized by their membership in
certain oppressed groups societies
understood entirely as a meat matter of
power not freedom and the only thing to
do is to resist those in power on behalf
of those out of it and seeing that as
the core reality of humanity divided by
race gender sexual orientation gender
identity and these themes are being used
and spread throughout the educational
system including the elementary school
system now as a way to transform society
in the most radical lines to abolish
nature to abolish the difference between
men and women to insist that all
differences in outcome in almost any
line of work or area of expertise is
entirely due to forms of oppression and
nothing else this ideology of course is
now the orthodoxy being taught across
American education it is the orthodoxy
being taught every day deliberately by
the new york times it is not something
that most regular normal americans
believe in they still believe in the
ideas of
opportunity meritocracy they just want
to be able to succeed and know that in
this particular economy the chances of
their succeeding is extremely small in
the process of the elites of the
Democratic Party left moving drastically
to the left and indeed moving towards
open borders more explicitly is a
function also of Donald Trump but
Trump's genius you want to call it that
is too so polarize the country to
advocate such extraordinary measures on
the far right that the far left has been
emboldened by this and the Liberals in
the Democratic Party have to say yes we
know we're up against this figure yes we
know he's doing all these things that we
despise but let's be sensible and let's
be moderate let's not take the bait
let's not go crazy let's not just oppose
him in every single respect to the
extreme that's a very very difficult
case to make in the mood right now on
the left and the right so my view for
what it's worth and all this is made
incredibly worse and has been created in
part by social media which means the
elites are really talking to themselves
I have no understanding what's happening
outside that's why they could have
nominated Hillary Clinton an insane act
given her popularity and her credibility
and now they've decided they want
Hillary 2.0 but not quite as charming
but they cannot help themselves and the
liberal tradition liberalism itself has
collapsed you see this also across
Europe center-left parties have
completely imploded and the Labour Party
in Britain the biggest and most
successful one recently has only
survived because the far left has taken
the whole thing over so I think short
term we're going to have major
polarization and the Democratic Party if
they nominate Warren will lose that's
what I suspect of course anything could
happen
but I also think that if we continue
with what we have in power and we have
no reforms in economy then that will be
a very short-term victory for the right
and the what's coming is a landslide for
the very far left it will come when it
comes is simply a matter of time and
whether the Democratic Party can marshal
that energy to win elections is is the
real question there they're the most
useless political party in the West and
they can screw it up but the tide is
with them thank you
[Applause]
okay thanks to all our panelists for
those presentations I want to give them
some opportunity to respond to one
another would anyone like to begin that
please and if you get the microphones at
your seat are working and kind of
referee it from up here if I can bill
how would you respond to Andrews
presentation is there an emerging
Democratic majority that's just ten or
fifteen years away or sooner is this it
is it is on yes I guess andrew has a
much clearer crystal ball that I do if I
wanted to be contentious you know I
would say that the Tories and the UK are
giving the Democrats a pretty good run
for their money for for uselessness but
but let's not go there we can the the
elections coming up oh yes
I I don't share the view that the
Democratic Party has capitulated to
far-left forces the nomination of
Hillary Clinton was you know was labeled
an insane act would it have been saner
to nominate Bernie Sanders who was the
only available alternative I don't think
so and as you know as I read for example
the Democratic primary electorate in New
Hampshire just in today's Wall Street
Journal I published a piece about the
views of that electorate they are not in
favor of revolution there they are in
favor of reform they would like that
reform to draw on the best ideas and
energy from both political parties and I
think that the view of the Democratic
Party that you see if you look at it
through the prism of campus leftism it's
really a crazy many crazy mirror
caricature of the actual rank-and-file
of the party no doubt the Democratic
Party of today is nothing like the
Democratic Party of 1960 but I hasten to
add that the Republican Party of today
is nothing like the Republican Party of
1960 either both have changed neither
has changed in a direction that I
particularly like but I think perhaps
it's my role on this panel to be a
defender of the Democratic Party because
no one else in this panel seems to want
to occupy that role but Bill you were
defending a Democratic Party
in New Hampshire that included I think
if I have it right 30 to 40%
independence of that group as I remember
your article 30% voted for Donald Trump
so that's correct the group you were
describing is not really the Democratic
electorate as I know it or is Andrew try
to describe it right wrong these are are
clearly right let me suggest let me
suggest the compromise which is in fact
bill you most regular Democratic voters
are not far left at all it's irrelevant
the activist base is selecting far-left
candidates to pick from with the
exception of Biden who is clearly too
old to do what he's doing and it's those
elites that are determining the policy
and I see absolutely no one for example
among any of the Democratic candidates
was pushed back the slightest bit on the
question say of immigration or of the
social justice agenda in fact they've
all completely capitulated to it I don't
agree with that either for example for
example Biden was not the only Democrat
who pushed back against the proposition
that unauthorized border crossing should
be decriminalized not the only one by
far well who else who else because I
think they all put up their hands ban it
no I believe senator Klobuchar from
Minnesota did not accept that
proposition and a couple of others it
divided the party and many of the people
who put up their hands I think will have
cause to regret it if they're not
already regretting it I would say one
other thing that if you have lots and
lots of people fighting for half of the
party and only one or two people
fighting for the other half of the party
there's a certain tactical advantage to
the less densely populated field and you
know senator Sanders is not fading
nearly fast enough for the warran forces
and as long as he stays in the race and
gets above
the 15% threshold she is going to have a
very hard time commanding a majority
within the Democratic Party so I guess I
just have I have a very different view
of what's going on and I do not agree
with the proposition that the elites are
driving the entirety of the debate
within the Democratic Party maybe I'll
put one one question of the panel before
we we open it up and I haven't heard the
issue of gun control raised yet this
morning but it's certainly very much on
that the current public policy agenda
and I wonder especially as important as
that is to some of the electoral battles
that you're all speaking to if you might
say something about about the party in
the and the gun control issue well I'll
be happy to first of all you know first
of all the Second Amendment is in the
Constitution and as interpreted by the
Supreme Court and the Heller in the
Heller decision it's the law of the land
and so the question is what is
permissible within the Constitution as
interpreted by the Supreme Court and of
those things that are permissible what
is good public policy and do Democratic
proposals map on to those contours
comfortably I would say this every
single survey that I've seen shows
between 85 and 90 percent public support
for universal background checks every
single one a majority of Democrats
Republicans independents and NRA members
are all in favor of that and I believe
that I you know I believe that the the
support for that proposition is strong
enough so that a candidate who takes the
other side of that position is going to
have a problem do I do I think that the
involuntary confiscation of classes of
weapons
is either constitutional or politically
prudent no I don't but there is a lot of
daylight between the involuntary
confiscation of classes of weapons on
the one hand and the status quo on the
other and it's the task of reasonable
people in both political parties to find
that sweet spot let me try to put that
in the context of campaigning I'm gonna
try to talk in plain English you will
win a Democratic primary taking as
strong a position on gun control as you
feel prudent there is a sense and I
think rightly of the moral urgency of
background tracks out of the universal
nature red flag laws lie and try and yes
there is sixty five seventy percent
support in the Democratic primary for
assault weapon ban so you're predicting
the nomination of better O'Rourke is
that correct I think I made very clear
that that is not what I'm predicting and
I do think you're owed me anyway
but what I would say to Bill's point is
the Republicans and their leader Mitch
McConnell has basically said I'm not
doing anything unless the president's
going to sign it and as we sit here
today it doesn't look to me like
anything's gonna get done we might and
bill could be right on this the
overwhelming power of the background
check issue could be one that gets
through the Senate and the house but
despite the numbers that bill sites
which are absolutely correct Mitch
McConnell has been unfailingly resistant
and the real change is in the 2018
midterms I was working for Mike
Bloomberg's PAC I USA we use the gun
issue we used it unabashedly and without
any apology
but of course supporting Second
Amendment and we had breakthroughs in 21
of the 25 districts we campaigned in and
in none of those districts was support
for gun control anything but a political
positive so I think the Republicans are
behind the curve on the issue but I do
also think that the strength of a very
weakened and I daresay allegedly corrupt
NRA is such that the other side of the
issue has been weakened what I will say
is one of probably the few people here
who has debated the issue extensively
against the right is the argument
against gun control of the type that
Bill's describing or I am either both
advocating and describing is you're
taking our guns away and as specious as
I think that claim is if you're just
talking about background checks until
recently that claim and the fervor that
the right attaches to it has been
surprisingly effective as I said 2018
much less effective and it is in my mind
an open question how the issue will play
out in 2020 but if the Republicans don't
embrace some sort of compromise on
getting rid of the loopholes on
background checks I think it'll be a
huge potential Democratic issue in the
general election
okay I think with that we will go to
questions from the audience there are
some folks with microphones and so if
you could raise your hands and they will
come to you and and let you use those to
address a question to the panel I see
several hands over there I'll let you
guys just figure that out please sir my
question involves whether the other two
gentlemen agree or disagree with mr.
Sullivan that capitalism has been an
unabashed failure in the Western nations
I don't feel that I feel that the
younger generation has had great
difficulties because of the increase in
college tuition and some of those
aspects but to call it an unabashed
failure in the West astounds me can I
just respond to that obviously
capitalism has been an incredible
success if you look at the the entire
world and it's certainly been a success
in the last 20 years for large numbers
of people in developing world it is not
working or middle-class and
working-class Westerners it is actually
making it incredibly hard for them to
scrape together a living the data is
simply unanswerable it's the idea that a
capitalist economy will benefit everyone
has disappeared because it is not true
anymore
and I think people on the right need to
get get real about that that's why we
have Trump that's why we have a
rejection of what you might call
neoliberalism because in the end it was
a victim of its own success and the
forces of mass migration and of
globalization and a free trade have have
essentially decimated the potential for
ordinary people in the West to actually
earn a living and to see the living
standards of their kids be higher than
their own a right
now the living standards are going to be
lower and that is not a success I'm
sorry it's not a success in the last
we're talking about this particular
period in time and it's really hurting
that's why our entire politics are the
way they are to me the answer that
Andrew just gave now as opposed to his
earlier answer is very close to my own
view look if you look at the numbers
that Donald Trump cites
in each of his speeches it's hard to
disagree with his reports about lowest
unemployment rate highest levels of
employment for minorities and it's hard
to look at those numbers and say that we
have been anything but successful when
you look at the poll data his rating on
handling the economy is about 10 points
12 points higher than his overall
approval rating but it injures right it
would be absolutely wrong to conclude
from those numbers that we've had the
level of upward mobility and reduction
in income inequality that a healthy
society sees to me the reason I talk
about jobs in my initial presentation is
the Democrats need a narrative that is
both Pro capitalism Pro growth I think
it's what Bill if I can flatter him
again with plagiarism called inclusive
growth and I think if the Democrats are
able to do that as part of an
overarching strategy that doesn't
necessarily focus exclusively on culture
they will be inestimable stronger in
November 2020
my view is that if you look at the
history of market economies extending
back hundreds of years they go through
periodic periodic episodes of crisis or
deep challenge and the task in each case
and it has been successful up to now is
to make the necessary policy adjustments
in the framework of market economies so
that they do achieve their objectives
including widespread benefits to the
populations not just developing
countries but have developed countries I
believe that in the wake of the economic
crisis of 2008 2009 we are again in one
of those periods the argument within the
Democratic Party is whether capitalism
should be adjusted or abandoned I
confidently predict at the end of the
day that the market economy in the
United States will be adjusted not
abandoned there will be responses to a
series of particular challenges
including the cost of health care the
cost of the cost of higher education the
fact that many young people today even
in their 30s view the prospect of
homeownership is almost unimaginably
distant which is a profound
transformation from the way thing way
things were in other words we're not in
the 1990s anymore and the optimism that
we had about having a winning hand and
needing only to play it out reasonably
skillfully has dissipated I think for
good reasons and we now have to think
more deeply about the adjustments to the
market economy that are that are
necessary many Republican thinkers for
example are talking about systems of tax
credits or wage sup
that's for low and moderate-income
workers not to put too fine a point on
that that is a form of redistribution
within within the market system many
Democrats agree with that approach I
would also say in conclusion that the
government every year publishes a
comprehensive report on income and
poverty and the report that came out
just last week showed that corrected for
inflation the median earnings of men
working full-time year-round have not
increased since 1973 those are those are
official government that that is a
failure right that is a failure god is
you know that is I would say evidence
evidence at the very least that
something has gone wrong
that needs to be fixed whether socialism
is the name of the fix
I am very skeptical me too bill I'm not
advocating I'm just trying to analyze
what's going to I would vote I would
support sure Biden over over that but
I'm just trying to explain why I think
the forces that have that have swept
over people which they're responding to
by very understandably wanting to
curtail free trade wanting to curtail
immigration wanted it to make themselves
feel more secure in this in this in this
economy how is one of the central issues
of our time it's it's it's defining all
of our politics and and again I think if
it weren't for immigration and if it
weren't for their cultural marxism Dems
could do really well and adjust
capitalism just in a more redistributed
way well I think you know I think we
largely agree on that point whether we
agree on the underlying analysis is
interesting so for example to let's
let's take full-time male workers as a
as an analytical baseline two big things
have happened
in the past half-century first of all
the surge of women into the paid
workforce that is domestic competition
and secondly the creation of what
amounts to a global labor market which
did not exist until the collapse of
communism the fall of the Berlin Wall
and the entrance of China fully into the
global economy I think we have not yet
begun to think through how can how
countries like the United States can
respond to economical huge tectonic
economic forces like that and I don't
think those responses are going to look
a lot like the 1990s my favorite decade
or the 1980s presumably the favorite
decade of a lot of the people in this
room okay let's let's get another
question over here please thank you
gentlemen for participating today and
this kind of follows the the first
question is if the left is in an
inexorable movement to socialism you
know the the phrase of something about
the definition of lunacy is doing the
same thing and expecting a different
result
how do socialists on the Left expect a
different result from every instance
we've seen of socialism ie the Soviet
Union and its demise and and Venezuela's
you know sinking into a pit of if I
would quote my president a [ __ ]
well to put it as simply as pop I can
make my answer very short I do not see
the Democratic Party as being on anacs
inexorable path towards socialism I see
it as being in the middle of a debate as
to how contemporary capitalism can be
adjusted so that the general welfare is
better promoted that under the status
quo that's the real debate that's the
constitutional debate what does the
general welfare require in current
circumstances and and it will the ants
debt the Democratic Party will never
arrive at jeremy corbyn's solution never
that's what the blair i'd said before it
happened I'm just trying to explain it
understand it that's all I just think
it's a very fertile time I I think if
you look at the rhetoric of Bernie
Sanders and Elizabeth Warren who were
getting 40% together in The Wall Street
Journal poll out today higher with their
combined vote than Biden's 30% their
rhetoric is explicitly socialist
their solutions clearly socialist and I
think Bill's right I don't think
capitalism is going away anytime soon
but we're gonna have a robust debate of
the type that I think even a few years
ago would have been unimaginable and I
think a good part of the reason are is
what Andrew suggests but let me let me
just offer a slightly more
straightforward explanation when we all
got out of school the presumption at
least in my world and what I saw when I
came of age was that there were
limitless possibilities tuition was
cheap healthcare was available and
affordable through private means or
you paid yourself didn't cost you much
jobs were plentifully available
opportunities for advancement clear and
that's all disappeared and I I see lots
of young people running a business as I
think the only full-time capitalist on
this panel and the degree of uncertainty
that I see and the degree of desperation
that I see of people with loans they
can't pay for jobs they are unable to
procure in a society that does not offer
upward mobility as bill suggested I
think gives rise to a level of
frustration that goes well beyond going
to constitutional principles and raises
real issues of anger frustration and
bitterness in a country with changing
demographics with a population that is
restive in ways that we had never
anticipated see mass incarceration
the new civil rights movement also
notice that the person who ran as the
candidate the president for the
Republican Party last time was in favor
of all the entitlements actually going
up told people they could have free
health care that would be cheap he just
had some answer to it he ran I mean he
was lying the entire time but he ran on
a far more progressive platform that and
also in against free trade than any
previous Republican ever had so if the
Republican Party has turned that left on
economics what do you expect the
Democratic Party to do now it's obscured
because the Republican Party right now
is just this cult but beneath and
because in empower the Republican Party
did the reverse it actually intensified
social inequality and intensified
climate change deliberately it's kind of
mind-blowing but in the politics of it
they definitely
they definitely tack left this one hmm
okay next question please thank you
I grew up in high school and college in
the early 70s and when I was in school
if there was a huge leftist movement
going on at the time anti-war anti
Vietnam youth the baby boomers were the
largest generation to come forward and
everyone predicted a seismic shift in
politics to the left I recall the
election of 1972 or the fairly unpopular
Richard Nixon in the press and in among
the colleges in the elite and I remember
a professor from of history from
Wisconsin George McGovern being the
vaunted Savior and income equality and
income guarantees being a substantial
part of his platform as well as being
what what in fact he was promoting now I
see Elizabeth Warren I see Bernie
Sanders and I see Donald Trump and your
projection Andrew about the
inevitability of the Millennials turning
left reminds me of another Tory Winston
Churchill and his comment about those in
their youth not being left versus those
as they come of age not being right I
don't see the inevitability of the
millennial generation and the success of
Zeke Z generation remaining left I think
the reality is that conservative
nationalism is a progression that is
bringing great results in this country
how do you address the historical
paradigm
well Nixon didn't govern as a right
winger that's for sure if you look at
his record many of us on the Left when
you strip out Watergate and you strip
out the unpleasant nature of much of
what Nixon
said would be very happy with a economic
and social record that was quite
moderate hence his 49 state victory and
I would just ask you to turn your clock
a little forward to the 74 election when
there was a sea change and even to 76
when Jimmy Carter was elected as a
southern governor promising he would
never lie to us now I'm not suggesting
that Jimmy Carter represents what we in
the Democratic Party stand for he most
assuredly does not but there was a
dramatic reaction in the 70s against
what the Nixon presidency produced and
indeed because Nixon governed as a
centrist we ended up in 1980 with a
continuation of a movement in the
Republican Party started by Barry
Goldwater to the to the right you're at
Proposition 13 in 1978 and you had the
nomination and election of Ronald Reagan
in 1980 so as I see the history I see it
quite different than you do but I would
also tell you that it's going to be
pretty hard for me as I look at the poll
data and see the Millennials two to one
left also with no no strength of their
Democratic allegiance a lot of them call
themselves independence not because
they're really independent but because
they're not aligned with any of the two
major parties so I think if you just try
to believe that political nationalism of
the type Trump is pushing he's gonna
command the majority of the Millennials
I think you're overstating the case and
let me add one other thing that for the
first time the Republican Party now
stands for massive borrowing the the one
thing the socialism was always about as
Margaret Thatcher said was spending
other people's money but there has never
been a president who spent other
people's money quite as wanton Lee as
the current one
now if perfectly massive amounts of
spending and huge tax cuts to the super
wealthy that's that's what he's done
when you have said it doesn't matter
what the budget deficit is we can run a
trillion dollar so a trillion dollar
deficit every year and we know the
Republican Party will still cheer us of
course as an opening on the left to say
well if there's all that money around
you just found even though we were
massively in debt when you came to
office and we were in a period of growth
and you still borrowed all that money to
throw at the economy why can't you and
you just for the very wealthy why can't
you do it for the poor why can't you do
it for the working classes this is such
a powerful argument and I think that the
Republicans have completely ceded the
party of responsibility as it were the
party we can't afford that the policy of
the party of no we have to have limits
that is not the current Republican Party
actually hasn't been for a very long
time let me you know since Andrew and I
have disagreed on some points let me
agree emphatic ly with him on the point
that he just made and here here's the
bill of particulars I think we all
remember then candidate Donald Trump's
famous down the escalator announcement
speech at least we remember what he said
about Mexicans least I do
what we forget is something that he said
later in the announcement speech you can
check it for yourselves namely that we
have to save Social Security and
Medicare and Medicaid without cuts I
quote and then he went on to say we got
to do it and the an important part of
the meaning of Donald Trump's nomination
and election was the direct repudiation
of the economic and fiscal parties of
policies of the previous leader of the
Republican Party namely Paul Ryan right
trumpism on economics is the rejection
of Ryan ISM on entitlements
on the budget deficit and on trade and
you know and that move in the Republican
Party has fundamentally reshaped the
terrain of American politics and the
competition between the two parties and
I think we're just beginning to work
through the implications of that whether
we can whether we can live with economic
policies that are indifferent to the
sorts of things that Paul Ryan was
trying to do something about is another
question altogether but that's where we
are we eunuchs plan for one more
question
hi thank you for this very interesting
debate I did not go to Hillsdale College
we support Hillsdale I am probably the
last person that should get up and talk
about politics so I will not the title
of this conference this today was the
future of the Democratic Party I have
heard the word Marxism I hear the word
socialism I agree with you sir
there has been no one of the 27,000
Democratic people that are up there
talking about a platform that I learned
back in somewhat I think my younger
years so I ask you if you're going to
end this tell me is socialism for the
Democratic Party the future and is that
socialism defined because that also can
be when it's on steroids communism and
that is something we fought for years to
rid ourselves of so I ask you with your
intelligence your study and your
backgrounds what is the future of the
Democratic Party
I'll take a shot at that quickly I think
we are going to see the advocacy of
socialist policies by the Democrats by
their left-wing by the squad by Bernie
Sanders Elizabeth Warren continued
unabated through this election whether
we win lose or draw I don't think that
we're gonna be a communist Society I
think there's very little chance of that
though I didn't think Venezuela was
going to end up with Maduro either
though I see no evidence that his
cronies will do anything but end up in
our federal penitentiaries where many of
them belong for drug trafficking
that being said capitalism isn't going
away here
I think bills largely right that it will
face challenges and survive my point is
only those challenges are going to be
more pronounced more continual and more
vexatious than I think most Democrats
and certainly this Democrat would like
to see I don't think I would call the
proposals of say Elizabeth Warren
socialism and this is why what do you
think Margaret Thatcher was a socialist
she presided over free healthcare for
absolutely everyone and defended it
through a socialist delivery system for
three terms was Britain socialist under
Margaret Thatcher I don't think so
is is is public availability of
healthcare popular hugely popular what
is Boris Johnson doing now promising to
spend millions and millions and millions
of dollars on the health care system so
that everyone can have access to health
care universal access to health care is
not socialism it's it's it's it's a it
has been the foundation of every other
Western society so but I do think that
it will become more I read it for you we
just finished and I do think it's gonna
become more leftist and I do think it's
going to culturally
because the Wright has done such a
terrible job of engaging the next
generations is going to be much more
culturally and socially to the left than
we've ever seen before well I guess we
use it too me too
to end this discussion I think I've been
pretty clear that I don't think that the
future of the country is socialist let
alone communist and I don't think the
future of the Democratic Party is that
either what we are going through right
now within the party and within the
country is an effort and I think this is
what our party system is all about to
struggle with very real public problems
if you know if the economy is not
working well for everybody by the way if
it had been working well for everybody
Donald Trump would never have been
elected President of the United States
he represented a response to you know
the failure of the country over a period
of decades under Republican and
Democratic presidents to deal with the
problems afflicting the manufacturing
sector of the country to deal with the
problems of rural America of the absence
of capital investment in those areas etc
he represented one response to a very
uneven economic terrain and the
Democrats are now wrestling about what
their response to the same set of
problems should be we will not end up
with socialism on the Left we will not
end up with fascism on the right but
within ten years I think we will see
very significant adjustments to the
market system a much more aggressive
antitrust policy yes I agree with Andrew
more emphasis on redistribution for
those people who are working full time
and not making it in today's economy we
are likely to see
a real adjustment of finance for higher
education which is now in trouble
because in response to the financial
crisis virtually every state responded
with huge cuts in subsidies to higher
education shifting those burdens to
students and their families those are
the real debates were going to have and
you know and I think that hundreds of
years of betters have gone broke betting
against the power of the capacity of the
United States to assess and as Winston
Churchill put it when all other
alternatives are exhausted to do the
right thing thank you very much ok thank
you so we're going to reconvene at 10:30
so please enjoy a break in the interim
and join me in thanking these gentlemen
for giving us some things to think about
[Applause]